[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up you guys i'm denny
director joined by sophie scholl AC
thank you for hanging out with us this
is daily denny live and if you can
believe it we are now four days away
from the Royal way I know it's kind of
crazy were pumped about it you guys
which means there's four days for Prince
Harry too so as last while though I
wonder if he's having a bachelor party
you know what I hope William throws in
what if not William some friends come on
Harry
it is Harry we all know Harry's had that
wild past we all know it
in fact I love him for I do love him for
it well we do know that Harry loved to
visit a pub back in his single days and
our lauren zima is on the ground now
where she visited a couple of Harry's
old haunts we are here doing a little
bit of a Prince Harry pub crawl in honor
of the Royal Wedding Prince Harry
marrying Megan Markel and I'm here with
Jose general manager of Eclipse hi Jose
tell me what area of London were in
because I still don't have my thing okay
and Prince Harry used to come here back
in his youth is this true yeah he used
to come quite often
okay maybe even sat at this very table
so how does a royal just go out to a bar
Jose says Harry would show up with
security and a small group of friends I
mean he used to be always talking to
women he was a very like way known for
being a ladies man so he was always
flirty
according to Jose Harry liked cocktails
made with vodka and gin and so you have
a signature shot here and what is it
called
it's go crack a baby a crack baby show
what is in the crack baby so crab we
should do is good vodka passion fruit
puree Chambord which is a raspberry cure
some champagne it's quite an amazing
drink it was originally invented here so
did Prince Harry take a crack baby shot
but Harry's getting married now these
days Jose sees him shopping or jogging
in the area not partying and you guys
have come up with a drink in celebration
of Harry and Megan's wedding the melons
Sparkle tell me about the melons so we
have I mean I would most famously for
the last 20 years is a watermelon monkey
and they were just basically twist a
little bit and have it with a gene which
is a British spirit ability of sugar and
then just shake it with lots of love
we're gonna blow it out and give it a
drink the melon Sparkle oh yeah
Cheers again oh yes oh yes you can feel
them I love it like they love each other
you guys are really making our work day
fun okay perfect so let's do a crack
baby shot and I take this whole thing
yeah I mean you can zip it but building
the whole thing and maybe one more for
the road hey our stops are all close to
Kensington Palace where Will and Kate
live now and Harry and Megan will live
to top number two on our Prince Harry
pub crawl is bumpkin where not only did
Prince Harry party but will and Kate as
well
Amy Kyle and manager here at bumpkin we
are taking a look back at the places
that Harry used to go and he was a
little more single a little bit more of
a partier and we've heard that here at
bumpkin you even served him I did it was
very friendly quite outgoing very polite
everything is seasoned thank you okay so
I'm touching someone who has touched
Harry Amy this makes you on another
level when you get that call do they
call you and say Prince Harry is coming
they vote mentioned in particulars they
will see a member of the royal family
then you can use your imagination from
there but and they obviously don't want
you to like anything to the press so I
think this is one of the reasons they
don't specifically tell you what royal
how did you react to the news that he
was settling down and settling down with
an American actress Megan Marco it's
peculiar of X G cos Harry was known as a
party animal but I guess obviously found
the love of his life bumpkin came up
with two royal wedding weekend drinks
the Harry and
Megan this is the Harry it's a gin-based
cocktail very light and refreshing on a
port so this is the Megan made with
American whisky so we're representing
our two nations here gin British
American whiskey for Megan all right
well let's cheers to Harry and Megan and
to you Amy bumpkin is really feeling the
Royal Wedding fever with their decor so
we had to get bumpkin at bump guys after
a couple crash baby shots at Harry and
the Megan I'm a little bit done with
this pub crawl I'm not sure if I can
handle things like Harry so we're gonna
call it Butthead / TT online comm where
we have so much more on Harry and
Megan's favorite spots all over London
you can get the inside scoop by so much
fun I'm so jealous I know now I'm
thirsty
you actually visited London before yeah
I did I was about a year ago I don't
remember the pub scene before you were
pregnant oh yeah before I was pregnant
yeah it was fun this was fun I hope you
know what I hope make it enjoys a pint
with her husband after all is said and
done maybe Sunday I bet they have nice
signature cocktails I plan he bet oh I
wonder what those are a nice little uh
what is it Pimm's Cup
yeah Pimm's Cup may be a little custom
brew you know what we did we should have
had cocktails here guys I apologize I do
that oh that's right Bob tell me Wow
trying to give cocktail to the pregnant
lady uh you guys so of course that's all
the fun Harry used to having his single
days which got us thinking about his
past relationships and his xx's you did
some digging I did some digging I did a
little a little trip down memory lane
so Harry's had quite a few this is some
flames you know when you're in the
public eye you you get spotted with
people look like Harry you know the
girls must flock absolutely you're a
royal you're cute come on so he's had a
few high-profile former flames that we
all remember I think Chelsea Devi of
course is one of them now Harry dated
Chelsea on-again off-again from about
2004
until 2011 and during that time she
actually attended a few very
high-profile events with the family
including harry's army pilot graduation
in 2010 she also attended Harry's
brother Williams wedding in 2011 okay
that's a good he's gonna say that's a
big deal that's a huge deal actually
they did end up splitting shortly after
that it did sound like wedding bells
might have been ringing after he and
Chelsea broke up when he dated Cressida
bonus there was speculation that she
could be the one alas that did not prove
to be true they were introduced by
Harry's cousin Princess Eugenie they
split in 2014 citing public scrutiny as
an actor though which is kind of wild to
me because you really need to know what
you signed up for when you're dating a
royal let alone marrying them which is
crazy so that's why we've talked about
this I feel like Megan must really be in
love with Mary to go through this I mean
you are under the public eye and of
course part of the monarchy yeah you're
kind of signing your life away and I
mean whatever happens in the
relationship whether it you know whether
it's forever or not this is the rest of
your life you are Harry's ex for the
rest of your lives
so yeah Aly from facebook says I thought
Harry was for sure going to marry
Chelsea they were together forever they
were I didn't you it was such a long
time and you know it was young love
young love and also you know what time
doesn't mean that much in the grand
scheme of things it's like you can't see
forever with that person then you got to
get out yeah and there is something to
be said for the little tumultuous
relationship again something something
wasn't right well there I'm here he did
have a few more short-lived flings one
of which was with the British X Factor
judge Carolyn flack he was linked to her
during one of his off-again moments from
Chelsea oh they were on a break he was
also linked to Florence Bru Danelle
Bruce
she is a lingerie model and descendant
of the Earl of Cardigan they were linked
in 2011 lingerie model in there
surprised by that I'm not guys I have no
surprise like that but this all led to
Megan
nice American actress that we love let's
get into Megan's exes shall we most
notably of course is her first husband
that's what's so crazy about the fact
that Megan is marrying Prince Harry and
being a part of the royal family is that
she used to be married before this was a
huge deal when it first came out that
Harry and Megan were dating in fact that
she was divorced was just appalling
exactly but that's why now I'm like so
excited for this whole thing because I
just feel like they're totally shaking
up the monarchy you know they're
breaking protocol it's modern love
modern royalty okay listen we watched
the crown we know how it used to be
exactly it was not this easy so good on
Megan and Harry they must really love
each other but she was on married to
Trevor
engleson they met in 2004 and what in
2011 so I mean they were together for a
really long time talk about long-term
relationships they quietly split in 2013
and guys get this in a funny twist of
fate deadlines reported that Trevor
actually is producing a comedy series
about a man who's who the wife leaves
him for a British prince I love that
sound familiar familiar but it's all
truth it's not that factual you know but
a while before Megan and Harry did get
together it's it's not that dramatic I
will say though I will say it's a great
idea for a TV pilot but ya know it
didn't quite happen like that because of
course she also dated Cory Vitello a
Canadian celebrity chef before she met
Harry he's a little hunky good good on
you but yeah she dated the the Cory for
about two years and he's pictured here
with Giada De Laurentiis
so you know got a good eye you know that
powder out of roasted chicken exactly
she was roasting a chicken when harry
popped the question
yeah she's a cook she's a good cook uh
there was also speculation that she
might have been more than friends with
pro golfer Rory McIlroy that's correct
right though they never confirmed they
never comfortable people suspected that
they were together yeah this was back in
2014
he's a cutie too they are they said
they're just friends so we'll leave it
to that yeah they're just friends but
she found him she found herself a prince
guys she found herself with Prince and
what a good one too we are so
excited for Harriet Meghan I know you
guys are too were seeing a lot of love
coming in from YouTube and Facebook
Danny says Harry seems to have changed
his bachelor ways for Meghan
he does he does seem like a new and
improved man doesn't he feel like he's
ready to settle down
yeah I think him you know I think it's a
good time in his life I think he's
maturities a little older you know
Meghan is a mature well-spoken woman
with you know her own career and and
they both share that passion they both
share that passion for philanthropy you
know I mean I feel like right it's such
a key she fits in nicely
we know that the royal family
appreciates her and they know she's
gonna be a huge asset to their their
mission you know so good on them for
Harry you got a good one too it's not
just her it's pretty she's beautiful
gorgeous beautiful beautiful yeah can't
wait to see that dress I keep talking
about it every day we're gonna bring the
dress you know what do you have a vision
of what you think it's gonna look like I
think it'll be modern and it'll
obviously there's a protocol in like
what you can wear you know she has to
wear sleeves and stuff like that all
right you guys well that's all the time
we have for today thank you for joining
us of course we'll be back here again
tomorrow 12 p.m. Pacific for another
live episode of The Daily denne the
countdown to the royal wedding is on
guys can't wait all right thanks for
watching thanks to Sophie for spilling
the tea on all those that you guys have
a good day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]